Um
Today's speaker is Don Sub Rhee, um
who is in um who is a postdoc uh scholar
in Courant Institute at New York
University. Um just to introduce uh our
speaker today briefly, he previous his
postdoc uh position, he was a um true
assistant professor at Columbia
University. And he received his PhD in
applied math at the University of uh
Washington under uh the professor
um
Randy LeVeque and co-advised by um
Gunder Ohlmann uh in math department. Uh
today um Don Sub uh is
is going to talk about instilling
nonlinear shock waves, nonlinear model
reduction for transport dominated
problem using deep neural network.
So, please enjoy. Um no with with
with no further ado, Don Sub, uh here
you go.
Um over to you.
Thank you. Uh thank you for the
introduction and the invitation. Um
Yes, so uh
I'm going to talk about uh
uh model reduction for transport
dominated problems.
And uh
as is well known, uh transport dominated
problems are or or you know, similarly
moving interface problems or one uh are
kind of hard to handle with traditional
uh reduced uh models. And uh me and uh
my collaborators, we've been looking at
ways to remedy that. And uh we believe
that uh the there's a particular deep
neural network that we could use to
overcome this problem.
Um so, to just to set the background, um
um here's the here's the outline. So, um
I'm not sure if I could get through all
of all of these uh bullets, but uh first
I'm going to discuss um when exactly low
rank uh representations, linear low rank
representations, which are crucial for
classical reduced models are limited.
Um, and how we can turn to non-linear uh
low dimensional representations.
Um, and I'm going to discuss very
special cases where there is actually a
very simple way to to achieve to
construct these low dimensional
representations.
And then we will talk about a depth
separation in model reduction in in the
second part. Um,
so this is where I will mention that
these non-linear representations we're
constructing uh in the first bullets uh
can be written in terms of uh
uh um
in deep neural networks with a certain
architectural structure and how these
could be used to um
uh reduce uh
uh construct reduced models even for
even when there's uh shock waves
present.
And in the third uh in the later part uh
if I could get to it is uh I'm going to
discuss a little bit about what's called
the Lax-Phillips representation.
Um, so the first half of the talk is
going to be restricted to spatial
dimension one
where things are uh as you will see it's
it's complicated already.
Um, but
there I believe there is a hope to
extend these results to multiple spatial
dimensions using a generalization of the
Lax-Phillips representation.
And um
these representations actually require a
certain an integral transform called the
Radon transform.
And um I will briefly very briefly
discuss uh a certain discretization
uh of the Radon transform that I've been
looking into, which is called the
approximate discrete Radon transform,
ADRT.
Um, and uh unlike the Fourier transform
the discretizations of the Radon
transform is far from a settled matter.
And um
um I believe that this new
discretization uh relatively new
discretization has has lots of desirable
properties that might help us in
extending um our
our our results to multi space multiple
spatial dimensions.
And um please feel free to uh stop me at
any time and ask the questions. And uh
my camera tends to
flicker sometimes and it it might add
like a green or purple hue. Um it's a
camera issue that I have. So, please be
warned about that.
And I apologize.
Uh okay, so here's a one slide summary
of what uh model reduction tries to
achieve.
So, in scientific computing, um we tend
to write our approximation to the
solution as a linear combination of some
basis functions.
So, these RVs could be, you know, finite
element hat functions um or in the
finite element case, they could be jump
functions um and so on.
So, taking these uh linear combination
of some um
um basis function basis vectors or
functions RVs of n and belonging to some
dimension uh I mean a finite dimensional
space uh a linear space uh of dimension
capital Ns,
we try to solve uh some uh residual
minimization problem
uh which I can summarize here. So,
roughly speaking, um finite element
volume difference methods could be uh
considered as solving this type of a
problem.
Um
here T is uh for time. Um so, we'll be
considering mostly time dependent
problems.
Um and then however, for many query
problems um and inverse problems if you
or machine learning, you typically
require this solve uh upwards of 10,000
times for various uh parameter
dimensions. Um and uh it is infeasible
to actually sample the solution that
many times.
Um
I guess uh if you had a large enough
computer, you might be able to do it in
a small enough problem, but usually it's
not practical to do so.
So, um, to
a way to get around this is to construct
reduced models that is cheap to compute
by projecting to a low-dimensional
subspace called the reduced spaces. So,
I guess
I'm not sure if how familiar the
audience is with the the reduced model,
but I guess
um
So, all all you need to do is to project
your solution to this new dimension new
new bases uh C sub n
that belongs to a much lower dimension.
So, these bases will be n sub r
dimension as opposed to the full model
being n sub s dimension. And this
uh number of bases here is should be
much smaller than the number of
dimensions of the full model.
So, you derive a a corresponding
residual uh for for the reduced system.
And solving this gives you a reduced
solution which hopefully matches the uh
is close enough to the full solution so
that you can you can
solve this small much smaller system
uh as opposed to solving a large
complicated system. So, you can sample
this reduced system 10,000 times and
hopefully uh that'll be a good
approximation to sampling the full
model.
Um
Okay. So, but for transport dominated
problems, here's a very simple example
where this this uh fails miserably.
And it's the simplest example. So,
consider the transport equation in 1D
and you have an initial condition which
is this hat function in green.
And so, the solution is just this uh hat
function traveling to the right.
And suppose you sample this uh at a
certain time interval uh given here 0.1,
3, and 5, and 7, and 6, then the
supports are not even overlapping here.
So, these functions these these
snapshots uh the solution are taken at
different times are even orthogonal to
each other.
So, if this pulse was narrow enough and
your domain large enough, then you'll
end up with a completely orthogonal set
of snapshots.
And therefore, a low low-dimensional
reduced spaces cannot exist um if you
want a certain certain accuracy for your
problem.
So, this
this is a this is a presence of a
familiar object to you notion
if you're familiar with reduced spaces.
The Kolmogorov n-width is
the best error that you can achieve with
a basis of dimension n.
Um so, suppose your your this curly n is
your solution manifold is the collection
of solutions for your PDE that depends
on time or parameter. Um
and you want to approximate this every
member in this the solution manifold by
a linear combination of some uh some
some basis functions
basis functions of dimension n. So, you
take a a member of the
reduced spaces and you try to
approximate all of the members as much
as possible.
And
you want to approximate all of them with
some some error and that error
uh with a
when you're using a basic reduced spaces
of fixed dimension n is given by the
n-width.
Uh
this Kolmogorov n-width tells you
how how well you can approximate your
solution manifold with a with a linear
basis of dimension n.
So, for example, if you have a decay of
your n-width that is exponential
decaying in respect to n, then you it
means that you have a very good basis
function
available.
But, so if you Over and Out and Gerstner
showed for this very simple example, so
as opposed to a hat moving, now you have
like a jump moving.
Um in this case, you can actually
analytically bound the
at bound the end with.
So, the end with here uh decays like
this end to the minus 1/2.
Uh and this is a very slow rate.
And when you have this
slow rate, it means that no matter how
well you can you try to construct
reduced basis representation,
you you you're about to fail.
However, uh so
there is a there is still is a
low dimensional structure available for
these these types of problems.
Um which is uh if you look at that that
that becomes apparent when you look at
the characteristic curves.
So, it is this well known um the 1D
transport equation, the solution is
given by
the method of characteristics. So, you
have x t is just the u not composed with
x minus t.
So, while the solution manifold itself
is not low rank, if you look at the
characteristic curves, this x minus t,
you can view as
uh some some inverse of a
diffeomorphism. So, or inverse of a map
that transforms to the the domain to
itself.
And so, this
t sub t is just a representation of a
characteristic curve emanating from
point x.
And this
x minus t can be
represented as a inverse map of x plus
t.
Right? So, I guess uh
I can't see anybody's faces, so I'm not
sure if people are finding this too too
too simplistic. But uh so, this x plus
t, if you if you kind of
uh
multiply by one, then you can see that
this is actually a low it has a low rank
representation in terms of space. So,
it's just a identity times some
coefficient that depends on t
um and the ident the identity map x
uh multiplied by one. So, constant
constant one times t and identity times
one.
So, this this
uh capital T sub T, which represents uh
the characteristics curves propagating
forward, uh has a low rank
representation, although the solution
manifold itself
does not.
And um in a in a very very simple case,
uh uh
when you when your characteristics uh
curves are very smooth and they're very
very very regular,
you can represent this with a very small
number of terms.
So, you you do obtain some sort of a low
dimensional representation of your
solution.
And um
so, in a very simple case, in a very
simple special case, you can actually
construct this uh approximate this
capital T sub T
uh very efficiently um for a class of
scalar conservation laws uh using using
what's called the DIP maps, uh which
I'll I'll mention a little bit here. So,
this is a very uh special case when this
capital T sub T can be constructed very
very analytically without without a lot
of approximation.
So, what you try to do here is that this
pulse, uh which is the uh initial
condition at zero, is traveling to the
right. You do what's called a monotone
decomposition. So, you take these uh
monotone parts. So, you express your
initial condition and your uh solution
at the later time as sum of these uh
monotone functions.
So, uh and once you've done that, these
monotone functions, they correspond to
certain cumulative distribution
functions.
So, you can kind of uh you can apply uh
what's called the uh monotone
rearrangement map that takes uh this
distribution to distribution
and distribution to distribution. So,
um this only really works in the case
that the monotone parts are matching.
So, I guess if you have a uh monotone
increasing part and a decreasing part
and uh uh at time zero, and the same is
true for all future times or parameters,
then you can apply this map.
Um, and this map, uh, if you
uh, this this is monotone rearrangement
map, which is a term that comes from
optimal transport, gives you, uh,
snapshots of these
uh, transport.
And once you've done that, you these
transport maps, which are, you know, um,
you you uh, you're you take your
monotone function, and then you compose
it with the the inverse of the monotone
function at another time, um, you can
take an SVD of these approximate
transport maps.
And you can see that the while the while
the original POD of the solution that I
called has a very slowly decaying,
um, singular values,
uh, the
the transport modes themselves actually
have a fast, uh,
fast decaying singular values.
Um, and a similar notion could be
constructed. So, so, then we just uh,
briefly mentioned that you can also
interpolate
um, using these transport maps. And uh,
so these uh, transport maps are
approximate, but they're approximate to
they are approximations to the true, uh,
characteristic curves. So, for example,
if you take a Burgers equation uh, with
this uh,
initial condition, and then you you
evolve it forward, and then you
construct these transport maps and
interpolate in between them, then they
actually match up, um, exactly. So, they
are, uh, these transport maps actually
approximate
the the characteristic curves.
Okay. So, um, I mean, that's a briefly
case brief case when when these
transport maps could be constructed very
very explosive.
Um, but uh,
regardless of that,
what we've done is this is the the
classical reduced model, where you're
taking a linear combination of some
basis function,
and uh turned it into a long linear
representation
where your basis function is changing
over time. So, these C's are your usual
uh POD modes, for example.
You are composing it that with uh uh
these low-rank transport maps. So,
you're composing these uh basis
functions with the inverse of these uh
transport maps.
And this transport map, which
approximates these uh uh
characteristic curves, is is uh low-rank
object.
So, in an essence, what we're doing is
we're taking the solution manifold and
instead of trying to construct a one uh
set of linear bases that approximate all
the members
of of this solution manifold, um what
you're doing is you're constructing a
local basis for very local portion of
your manifold, let's say your initial
condition or or a perturbation of your
initial condition.
And you're applying this uh transport
map,
which will generate another transported
basis. So, you're constructing an
adaptive basis because uh this when you
compose uh your usual reduced bases with
a transport map, then you as you can end
up with a basis that is very different.
Um and so, for example, if you have a
time-dependent problem, then applying
this transport map will propagate your
reduced bases uh to uh along with the
flow
um so that you can represent the
solution um
uh well at all times.
Okay, so so
um this is uh very again, a very simple
representation that could be used to
construct reduced models. Um and we call
uh this reduced model uh map, manifold
approximation by transported
uh spaces.
Um so, as you've seen seen before, uh in
a very special case, you can construct
these transport modes or or or you can
solve a minimization to obtain these.
And once you have this transported
subspace, well, what's nice is that all
the interpolation methods like the uh
uh interpolation methods, they require
knowing only the uh your the
sampling your your reduced model at only
a uh uh certain uh small set of spatial
locations.
And
this this still applies when you apply
the transport map. So, these
interpolation points um where you can
evaluate these reduced bases to obtain
your coefficient
um are going to be transported along
with with your uh
with your transport map. So, as you
change the reduced bases along the flow,
your interpolation uh points will move
along with the uh exactly with respect
to these uh transport maps.
So, not only do you get uh a single
basis with the corresponding interval uh
interpolation points, you get uh a
transported basis
and corresponding interpolation points
for the changed basis.
So,
uh you you have a family of reduced
bases along with uh corresponding
interpolation.
Um
so, what's nice about this
representation is that you can now uh
evaluate and manipulate your reduced
model in a very very uh cheap way.
So, what you can do is uh you can time
step this uh non-linear reduced
representation um
and the details uh all of the details
and details are uh in our paper from uh
2019.
And uh so, what you can do is you can
alternate the evolving the coefficients
of your reduced bases and the
coefficients of your transport map
in sort of a uh semi-Lagrangian method.
So, it's a semi-Lagrangian in the sense
that you are changing the the by by
applying the transport map, you're
morphing the domain.
But, you're morphing the domain in a uh
very very specific and low-rank manner.
So, that can be done uh by only sampling
the transport map at the uh
two free interpolation points.
Um so by alternating
the update of your basis and your
coefficients you can you can solve a
uh
you can solve a parameterized PDE so
Um so let's look at an example. So here
is
a
a transport equation with a very very
smooth speed. So C here is a speed that
is some constant modulated by two
sinusoidal waves and so forth.
Coefficient here controls the amplitude.
Here mu2 and mu3 controls the the
frequency of of the modulation.
Um this equation is also called a color
equation representing dyes that are
going on the going uh
uh dye that's being transported along
the flow.
So if you started with the initial
condition that looks like this, and it's
traveling it's then not only going to
travel to the right like the advection
equation but its shape is also going to
undergo change.
Um although this is a very simple
problem to to solve with the full model,
it's actually hard to implement in this
small um in in the classical
um
so
let me give you the a brief analysis of
this problem. So we can actually lower
bound the end width of this uh solution
manifold.
Just as we provided lower bounds for the
simple case of a jump moving.
You can define what's called a sharply
convective class functions. I I will not
go into the details
but essentially you look at the
regularity
of what's what's moving.
So here
is a half sharply convective class of
functions which is where the jump
there's a strict jump that's moving to
the right. We saw that the end width of
that was lower bounded by n to the minus
half.
For example, if you have a slightly more
regular problem where where
your
your solution doesn't have a jump but
its derivative for example, then you
have what's called the 3/2 sharply
connected cost function, and in that
case you get a slightly faster decay.
So, whenever you have an alpha sharply
connected function, the N-width of that
manifold is going to be lower bounded by
N minus
N to the power of minus alpha.
Okay, so
for this problem, you can actually show
that
when your initial condition
has a discontinuity at some derivative,
so it's continuous
up to S minus one derivative, but not
the S derivative,
then there is a lower bound of the decay
of N to the minus S over 2.
Um so, for example, this home, which is
which is
piecewise analytic function where you're
combining cosine, for example,
with a constant function on the left and
the right, so this this yellow initial
condition
shows discontinuity if you take this
derivative.
So, this
will will give you N to the minus three
over two decay, which is also very slow.
You'd like it to be exponential for
classical Fourier series models, too.
However,
uh the
the C that we had earlier, which was
a constant plus analytic function, the
the the the variable C itself is
actually very, very smooth,
which implies that the characteristics
themselves are are also smooth.
And so, you can actually
find a polynomial approximation that
that does very, very well
with the Fourier spectral methods.
So, the N-width of the characteristic
curves for this case actually decays
very fast. It decays geometrically with
respect to N.
So, you can you can actually construct
the the representation as we had
earlier.
So,
uh while this is probably not an
exciting uh for 1D 1D example, um we can
evolve uh reduced spaces.
And what you're when we are solving this
evolution equation, we are really only
doing computations at these red dots.
So, although the the field is uh
it fills up the whole space and it's
actually um has the periodicity like 2
to the to the 10 or something. Able to
evolving this uh entire field, you're
only doing computations that uh that
scale with uh
uh the number of these red dots.
So, you're able to represent this uh uh
relatively complicated moving wave by by
doing computation at these points. And
these points are the interpolation
points. They're moving along with the
flow and this flow uh uh
uh if if if you uh track Wait, if you
plot the trajectory of these
interpolation points, then you can see
that they they are close to the the
perfect approach. Um and so on.
And you can look at this You can vary
the dimension of your reduced spaces
uh and how many transport modes you keep
and you can
you can see that the the basis size is
uh
um with with with 10 basis functions
composed with the four transport modes,
you can actually represent this moving
wave.
And um as you can see, if you in two uh
in this part, we show the difference in
P and if we
even if we increase the the resolution
of this grid on which we represent these
basis functions,
the the the run time per time step for
for this match representation in this
non-linear reduced model, of course,
does not increase
because the number of uh interpolation
points we keep and uh number of basis
size and your transport modes is is uh
is uh more or less irrelevant with
respect to the resolution of of your
basis functions and your transport
modes.
So, as far as I know, this is like
uh uh this is the first uh
um P-Nets result um where
the the runtime for time step is
completely decoupled from the runtime of
the full model
for for a non-trivial problem, a problem
that's not constantly or or
for the profile patching.
Okay. So, um coming back to our initial
title, we mentioned deep neural in the
title. Um
we we the the representation the the
linear representation we had earlier, it
can actually very nicely be put in terms
of deep neural nets.
So, as uh many of you will probably are
probably familiar with a feedforward
deep neural network is the setting that
we are we are uh going to restrict
ourselves to.
Uh feedforward neural network is uh
alternated uh composition of these
linear maps with a with a non-linear
activation function. And we will in in
particular we'll consider only the ReLU.
Um so, this is A's of one to A's of L
composed are our linear layers uh linear
maps which takes uh uh
um an input V um
of dimension um
N sub L and outputs another vector of uh
dimension N sub L plus one and the the
operation is completely linear.
So, these uh A's have uh these W's which
are parameterized which are our weight
parameters.
And depending on these W's, uh you you
get a different expression for X.
Um so,
for example, um if you want to
approximate a solution to the PDE
using a feedforward neural network, you
can for for any given function F, you
can find uh these W
W weight parameters that approximate
that that uh that given function.
And the number of parameters is of
course uh the the sum of all the weight
values in this matrix.
And of course it's the sum of S of L
times S of L transpose.
So um this deep neural network
uh which is supposedly a large network
it
can be uh
it can be be used to replace uh the
notion of full models.
So a full model
uh as you've seen earlier is just a
linear combination of uh these
functions. Um so they could be
considered as a one-layer uh deep or
deep neural network.
Um so uh if we have a representation of
the solution manifold uh that depends on
some some some parameter data this data
could be for example the time variable.
Um these uh
so for each uh S of data you'll have all
the weight parameters that depend on
data.
So uh for a solution to your PDE
you'll be able to set find a set of
parameters of of L um
so that your um deep or deep neural
networks which is defined by these
weights will be you'll be able to
approximate that solution uh very well.
Now let us assume the special case when
the
uh these weight parameters actually have
a low-rank structure.
So these individual weights in the
linear layers that apply up here in your
uh up here in your linear uh
um
the linear maps in in in your deep
neural network neural network suppose
you can find a a common uh linear basis
use of L and use of L.
Um
um and and this gamma sub L is now a
very small matrix.
So if your weight matrices have the
structure then you can form what's
called a reduced activation. So these
reduced activations are analog uh
uh the use state functions that we
talked earlier for the classical case.
Um and you can also reduce uh our our
linear maps or affine maps
um um to just a multiplication of this
uh various functions.
So, we can construct what's called a
reduced deep net.
Um and this deep network is just a deep
forward neural network with a very
specialized activation function and very
small affine transforms instead of a
very large one.
And um so for this F theta,
uh so this parameterized approximation
of your solution manifold, we can also
find a corresponding
uh uh representation in this uh reduced
setting.
And the key here is the number of
parameter is uh going to be going to
scale with the M sub L times N sub L
plus 1,
which is the size of your gamma,
uh which is the weight weight parameters
for this specialized network with a
special architecture.
And this M sub L and N sub L plus 1 can
be very very small
um
compared to the M sub L uh the the
parameters of the the usual uh deep
forward network.
Um
but it will be able to approximate uh
the solution manifold just as well just
by using this F theta.
Uh F sub theta R, which is the reduced
deep network representation.
So,
um
just to just to uh clarify what what I
what I'm saying. So, the
uh classical reduced model can be viewed
as a one-layer algorithm, which was uh
if you recall with a Lipschitz shape.
Um so, these
thetas are essentially trivial weight
functions.
And these basis functions are can be
represented as a uh when you freeze the
the the first layer um and uh
uh in a certain way, then you can
represent these basis functions well
because of their universal approximation
theorem.
Um so, you can consider the classical
reduced model as the one layer RDN.
And these one layer RDNs are uh
only applicable when you have when you
have a solution manifold that has fast
decaying end rate. Like for example,
they're exponentially decaying, then one
layer RDNs work very well. Classical
reduced models are of the class and they
work very well.
Um, the master representation, the
nonlinear reduced model we had earlier,
um also can be represented as an RDN.
Um, and in this case the solution
manifold has a slowly decaying end rate.
So, classical reduced models are out. We
cannot use them to efficiently solve the
problem. uh solution efficiently. Um,
and of course the one layer RDNs, which
are equivalent to classical reduced
models, do not apply here either.
However, uh as we saw earlier, the
characteristic curves and the wave
profiles themselves, they might each
individually have a fast decaying,
rapidly decaying end rate. And in this
case we have shown that our our
nonlinear representation, which you can
also represent as RDN, they can still
give you a a very efficient
parameterization or approximation to the
solution manifold of the characteristic
problem.
And in the machine learning literature,
when you have a deep uh network that is
able to uh achieve something that a
shallow shallow analog cannot, they call
it a depth separation. And this is a
instance of a depth separation um in
terms of a dimensionality reduction.
Um, and I guess I forgot to mention that
we had like the word "distilling" uh in
the title.
Um, and this is uh in the machine
learning literature uh uh an analogous
uh concept is called the knowledge
distillation. So, a knowledge
distillation is when you have a large
network
that has that can describe certain data
very very well. Um, you try to learn
from um
uh learn from that uh
representation of a much smaller network
with fewer parameters that is much
faster to evaluate and faster to train.
So, our reduced network is in in in a in
a very high sense
that it's a knowledge distillation
technique
that is specific to to this
this class of problems.
physical problems.
Um any any questions so far?
Um okay. So,
uh
So, here's a
a little more involved example where I
won't get too much into the details,
but I mean let's look at the Burgers'
equation, right? So, we've been
mentioning how these characteristic
curves could have a low-dimensional
approximation, but if you take an
initial condition that is
a simple monotonic decreasing function,
and it's
as it evolves, it it forms into a shock
wave.
Um so, the characteristic curves here
are not as regular. So, if you look at
the this is the characteristic
uh characteristic curves
emanating from various points
in in your domain,
and it's propagating.
And as you can see that there is a
merging of the characteristic curves
into a shock.
And so, if you view this characteristic
curves as a as a map from space to
space,
you can
you can form this plot. So, in
initially, you are working with the
identity map. So, there's the
characteristic curves
emanating at these points are not really
moving very much.
They're staying They're staying right
there.
And as you're evolving forward,
these
you're you're adding on another uh
you're adding another linear sum to a
scaled initial condition actually to to
your identity.
Um so, the the transport map
is actually by
a little bit on the left side like this
until it becomes uh a non-monotone
function in which which which
corresponds to the fact that the
characteristic curves are going to
overlap. So, there will be two
characteristic curves emanating from a
single
uh spatial point.
Uh and after that shock formation, you
form this plateau. So, this is the the
transport map uh from from your initial
uh spatial domain to the forward spatial
domain and
And as you can see, there is like a this
plateau that forms and propagates to the
left and to the right.
So, what this means is that the the
the transport map map themselves have
this traveling structure. So, if you go
back to the the uh our our initial
example of the advection equation when
when something wasn't moving,
um if there was an interface that was
moving, you had a lower bound on the end
width.
So, now this is this plot is showing
that when you have a uh a transport map
that is evolving like this over time,
the transport map itself can also have a
uh the collection of the transport maps
over time can also have a lower bound on
the end width.
So, um this is an example where
characteristic curves themselves they
have a singular propagating structure.
It So, in in a strange sense, the
characteristic uh curves themselves are
traveling.
So, there's a traveling feature in the
characteristic curve.
Um So, in this singular case,
there's no hope of constructing uh uh
essentially the the non-linear reduced
representation we saw before. So, this
breaks the mass representation
because your your transport map uh
there's no hope of constructing a
low-rank transport map there.
Because your now your characteristic
curves themselves are singular.
So, um we It's like a It's a sort of a
layered approach. So, if you start with
the one layer reduced network um and you
see that your Kolmogorov width is
decaying slowly, there's no hope of a
successful reduced solution. But, if you
compose it with a transport map that is
well-defined, there are cases where that
uh that gives you an efficient uh
representation.
And now in this case in the singular
case of the Burgers' equation, uh when
when there's shock formation,
um now you run into the same problem in
the inner layer for your transport map.
So, you have a lower bound on the
Kolmogorov width, in which case this uh
transport map itself cannot be
approximated in the lower standard, in
which
uh case you actually can
add more layers. Um so, I won't get into
the details because uh it's a little bit
very complicated, but this plateau
essentially
is also a traveling uh traveling
structure, like a traveling structure.
So, it's uh it's something tran-
transient to the right. So, if you
actually
subtract off the identity, you can see
that this is an interface moving to the
right.
So, it is this itself is also a
transport dominated object.
So, we can approximate this separately
with a with the inner layers of your
reduced network. And essentially, we can
prove that there is this uh uh uh
small parameter approximation. So, for
approximation of error of epsilon, we
can construct a RDN reduced network uh
whose number of parameters scales like
uh a log of epsilon, which which is
really small.
Okay. So, any questions so far?
Picture bar.
Okay. So,
um switching gears. So, this is uh all
in um
single spatial dimension, where you have
this notion of uh
method of characteristics. But, as as
soon as you go to uh even a linear
problem of Burgers' equation in multiple
dimensions, you lose this uh notion of
characteristics.
Now, of course, there's there are
special cases when you have like a
hypercomplex limit and you're doing
something similar. Topics that, uh, in
the gen- in general, uh, situations in
mathematics.
So, um, here is a an integral transform,
the Radon transform, which could be, um,
helpful in practice.
So, the Radon transform, um,
in this series just a integral of your
multi-dimensional function f
um, along some hyperplanes.
So, in 2D, let's say you have a 2D
function, uh, whose contours are the
circle written here. Um, the Radon
transform is just an integral over all
possible straight lines.
And this line is, uh, parametrized by
the omega, which is the normal direction
of your your your line, and s is the
distance of that line to to your origin.
So, you're transforming by integrating
your function f.
And this transform variables, which are
Radon variables, are these omega and s,
uh, which are just the angle and the
offset.
So, if you take, uh, this this f, uh,
which is this, uh,
uh, 2D function, if you apply the Radon
transform, you get another function in
2D,
where this omega is parametrized by the
orientation and s the offset.
So, you get these, uh, sinusoidally
looking, uh, waves.
Uh, this is the Radon transform of the
2D function.
And this is, uh,
uh,
uh, mono-famously used for, uh,
centralized tomography.
Um,
it appeared, uh,
regardless of the, uh,
like it was utilized from other problems
in in the early 1900s, uh, used by
Radon.
And the
the interesting property of the Radon
transform is that it intertwines the
partial derivative with the univariate
function.
So, if you have a partial derivative of
f with respect to the i-th variable,
um, if you, uh, apply the Radon
transform to that term,
you always get a derivative in in S. So
S was the offset variable uh multiplied
by some some uh some scaling factor.
So um for example, if you have uh a
multi-dimensional um advection equation,
uh you have to plus alpha cuz this alpha
is the direction of the propagation uh
dotted with the gradient. If you apply
the Radon transform to this equation,
you get an equation here uh which is uh
the the the time derivative of the Radon
transform is equal to some scalar
multiple, now this scalar is alpha times
the omega which is the angle of your of
your hyper plane uh times the Radon
transform derivative at the S. And this
is a 1D uh advection equation. So you
can take a multi-dimensional um
transport equation and once you apply
the Radon transform, it becomes a 1D
advection equation except that uh you
get a family of them for each angle. So
in a way you're doing a planar
decomposition of your multi-dimensional
transport problem and in each direction
you're solving a 1D advection equation.
Um and once you've solved it for each
direction, you can transform back and uh
get the solution.
Um
So for example, this uh imagine uh your
your advection equation is taking this
red pulse to this blue pulse.
The red pulse is going to be given by
the Radon transform of that is given by
this this red function over here.
Um and the matter of obtaining the the
solution after so if you apply the 2D
Radon transform uh to the 2D uh
advection equation in the one-one
direction, it's just going to propagate
this pulse over here.
And on the Radon variables for each
angle slice, you're only moving uh the
contour of the slice uh in uh a no path
in a certain speed. The speed will be
different for each direction, but it's
still a constant.
Um while it's that that might be that
itself is not very exciting for for the
transport equation, the same principle
applies for the 2D acoustic equation. I
think in the interest of time, let me
jump to this diagram.
So again, we have the Radon transform of
these two pulses.
And so these two
register as these sinusoidal waves in
the the Radon domain.
And so um if you look at this slice, um
you you see you see there is this one
hump.
And um so as you evolve the time
forward, you can go forward in time
and evolve the wave equation forward in
time,
um then um the solution on the in the
physical variables look pretty
complicated. And there's no hope of
constructing a transport map as we did
in 1D that maps this to to this um in a
very simple
um in a in a low rank way.
Um actually, you can you can prove that
there is that that is not possible.
Um however, if you look at the evolution
in the Radon variables,
for a fixed angle slice, this hump is
simply
uh
two two humps separating to left and
right and traveling.
So if you do some characteristic
variables transformation, then you can
separate this into just a one hump
moving.
So all the 1D apparatus we developed
earlier actually can be applied to the
1D slices of the Radon transform of the
object.
Um and this uh idea of um
the computing a low rank
uh of transform approximation in the
Radon variables is uh it has been
actually studied uh by people in in
image processing. Um
although they weren't really applying it
to to wave data um and all the way there
are any relation to the physical uh
uh differential equations.
Um
and this uh representation
uh let me go slide back. It's also
called the last build translation
representation
um which was used in their scattering
theory
uh in 1964.
Um okay, so now we arrive at the issue
of uh
efficient computation of the discrete
Radon transform. To to actually exploit
this uh computationally
um to go beyond the constant coefficient
case,
we
do need an efficient way of
uh applying the Radon transform and and
uh finding the inverse.
Um however, uh unlike the unlike the
Fourier transform,
um
the the
discretization of the Radon transform is
a little harder
um
in the sense that it is not a uniform
unitary transform.
Um the singular values do to decay for
that operator.
So, um
I've been looking at the this uh
fantastic actually transform uh called
the approximate discrete Radon
transform,
which uh discretizes uh what's called
the digital line. So, instead of
uh uh integrating over straight line,
um what it actually does is uh it looks
at the these uh
digital lines where the slopes are uh
slopes are broken up
um by by some binary
expansion.
And so, these
lines look a little broken.
Um so, these digits and these but these
digital lines have
uh a recursive uh property that allows
you to uh compute um the the the
summation over these digital lines
in in a fast way. So, O of N log N um
optimal access. O of N squared log N for
images of size uh N squared.
Um so, this is what a Radon transform
looks like. So, uh so, at each uh
iteration, let's say your image uh looks
like this.
Um it's a it's a recursive process. So,
um I don't think have the the
but but as each level you you form a
summation of broken lines
twice the length from the previous step.
So, in the end you get an approximation
to the the Radon transform of the full
full full line. And these are just in
summation of the pixels that that lie in
these are so-called vision lines which
are close enough to to the straight
lines but but are are they have this
jagged broken structure.
So, if you take the for example of the
full ADT
of this Radon transform, then you get
the picture that looks
this.
And
um
this is an approximation to the
continuous transform. So, what we saw
earlier didn't have this a changing
wedge shape. All you have to do is
stretch them and let them in a personal
way and then you can approximate the
continuous Radon transform with this
method.
This is a discrete discretized version.
And what's really interesting about this
discretization is that
William Press
at the University of Austin actually
found that it could be inverted to
machine precision using a full
multi-grid method.
And this sort of accuracy is not usually
expected from
the computer computerized tomography
field.
And
wondering why that was happening, we I
actually discovered that this actually
has a very actually has an algebraically
exact inversion formula.
So, among all the discretizations for
the
Radon transform, this is the only one
discovered so far that has an exact
inversion formula.
And we also can use that inversion
formula to characterize the range. And
this is very important for you know,
developing fast algorithms is the
approximation the approximate of the
Radon transform to exploit the the
uh the intertwining property.
Um
Right. So, um I think I am about out of
time. Um so, the summary is that uh
there is this uh depth separation for
reduced for non-linear hyperbolic
problems even in chance.
You can represent them very efficiently
with few parameters if you use uh this
particular um deep network with the
low-rank structure.
And this also generalizes to multiple
spatial dimensions, and these are
essentially a generalization of uh the
classical Lax-Wendroff presentation by
applying the the Radon transform.
So, these are some references. So, the
depth separation appeared in this paper.
Uh master thesis in this paper.
Um so, the Radon transform and
Lax-Wendroff uh was presented in in a
separate paper. And the exact ADRT
formula, uh this is actually a very
short four-page paper, uh appeared here.
Um this is to give a fast uh
approximation to the inversion formula.
And recently, we we uh characterized the
range. Um
um
So, these are the references. Um
and uh
Thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Don. So, thank you so much
for a very nice presentation. Okay, this
is a uh Q&A session. Uh we have
around 8 minutes. Um I see no questions
in in the chat room, but uh please um
you know,
um
step up uh if you have any question, you
can speak up.
Well, so the basic this is Jerome uh
Solberg. The basic idea I think is that
um in order to do these uh
manifolds, um
you need
um in other words the advection problem
you can't use a
a linear reduced basis. You need to use
what essentially is a quadratic basis in
some sense.
Right right right and and then you show
basically that
that for the Burgers equation you need
what essentially is one more so like a
cubic representation.
Actually it's
purely in terms of layers you need a
little more than that. Remember there is
was this inversion operation
so you have to implement that. But if
you yes yes exactly so if you block them
into let's say a block layers and one
layer is needed for the is corresponds
to the linear linear case and two block
layers are required for the smooth
smooth advection. And if you have
singular characteristics then you need
I think you need four block layers. I
think I ended up with four but but
four is sufficient I guess.
Four is sufficient
that's
that's singular
those are I mean I'm trying to think
about this in terms of uh
in terms of instead of like
singularities caused by like the Burgers
equation like shocks but in some sense
it's like somewhat like um
when you have you know multiple bodies
impacting
I wonder whether
you could characterize how many of these
things you would need to some extent
based upon the number of independent
bodies.
Yeah that's that's a very interesting
problem. So
I guess
when you when you when you have
particles and their trajectories are
singular as in if they hit an object,
then they they bounce off to a different
direction,
then that's representing that trajectory
banging on my door.
So
So So that's an interesting question,
huh?
Yeah, that I I believe it is. Um
What's
Yeah, there is lots of interesting
results about approximation properties
of deep networks. So
what what gives what gives us a little
bit of hope of handling these these
types of singular singular trajectories
is that if you have even if you have a
lot of them,
if the if the angles have some sort of a
similarity, um
the the ReLU deep forward ReLU networks
are able to create these jagged
approximations in a very efficient way.
Um
So
I think there's a paper by Yarotsky
which has exactly this this paper. So if
you have like a
a singular uh
a singular trajectory, but there's a lot
of similar ones occurring at different
spatial locations,
um I think you can approximate that very
well with a
um well well, at least in theory, with a
with a deeper network rather than a
shallow one.
Right.
Um okay, well, thank you so much for
your presentation.
Well, no, thank you.
Maybe I'll
write you later.
Okay, thanks so much.
Good.
Sounds good. Um any other questions?
Uh I have one. Um
Can you
What What do you envision for your
future direction after this? I see a lot
of examples.
Oh, I see. Yeah. I mean, there is
multiple ways that we're looking into
it. So here is
So
the the diagram that we had for maths,
so this is kind of like uh um
this is kind of like the the three
components that we need.
So, I guess like in the offline phase,
we were able to somehow construct uh the
inner layers.
Um like these weight matrix
approximations, the low rank
approximations in the inner layers
somehow.
Um which is a difficult problem. I mean,
I I showed like an example where this
could be uh computed for easy way, but
computing them in general is I think a
hard problem.
Um and for the and actually they need to
have this uh transport through this
tran- transport subspace structure. So,
these low rank representations
are what allows uh this uh during the
online stage to manipulate your um um
reduced deep network approximation by
adjusting only a few parameters.
Right? So, so what what we want is not
just uh some deep network approximation,
but we've got a deep network
approximation that we can plug into a
PDE
and uh evolve the reduced system in a uh
in a in a way that the number of uh
number of operations you have to do does
not scale with the full system.
Right? So, um what we're trying to do is
uh we for
constructing this is a huge problem. And
that's actually where um I think you
know you you you already have some
expertise in
uh
uh training these convolutional uh
encoders to extract this low dimensional
um
low dimensional um
representation of your solution
manifold. And what I'm looking into now
is what is the relationship between uh
um a conv network the DCNNs are they
train really well. And um as I've
already seen in your paper and and a
group of uh
uh people working on this, the the
convolutional neural networks have this
advantage of being able very easy to
train
and they're very stable and they're very
effective. So, how can we take a trained
convolutional network
and find an RDN representation of that
network is something that we're looking
into. So, if we could do that then
that's
that corresponds to like the first half
of the problem.
Um and I guess like at at the first
bullet of the problem and the second
bullet is to how we how do we evolve
these and so these RDNs have this low
rank structure and what we believe is
that when you hit this RDN with a
derivative
and you use backprop
we can apply like a sort of a empirical
interpolation for each layer of the
approximation.
So, whether we can do backprop in a very
efficient way and you know, find an
evolution equation when you plug these
things into the PDE, I think that's like
another important direction to look
into.
And
and
I think that's also ties with the way
that uh
these um
um these deep networks are
they can be plugged into these
you can form a functional essentially to
to solve the PDEs.
So, tying this idea of low rank weights
with uh
uh
uh with a with a backprop and forming a
forming a minimization problem that you
can solve for for uh
for these RDNs is actually another
another direction.
Um
Yeah, so I guess that that that's
actually includes two points two and
three.
But it's it's somewhat been done um
I guess for the autoencoder the the
first part is
works very well. And well, at least at
least that's to my knowledge. I think
the con- the convolution autoencoder
work
um works really well with the
with the training.
However, to get the speed up at the
online stage is is uh still a
non-trivial problem. I I believe uh you
have made some progress on that uh and
uh but it's still I think uh um many
people are kind of considering that
problem.
So, we have like the reverse problem, I
think. I think if we have the the if we
constructed these RTNs, then I think
it's uh much easier problem to actually
plug them into PDN solve them.
However, constructing them is still a
non-trivial problem. I don't think
anybody in the machine learning
community has looked at training these
RTNs from snapshot data.
So, it's a huge open problem where these
are as as trainable as as uh
convolutional neural networks are. Um I
mean, this the whole revolution started
with convolutional neural nets because
they they train so well.
Um so, if there is uh this complementary
uh
strength in in both directions and
and I think so, if we could somehow
borrow the trainability of the
convolutional neural networks by turning
them into the RTN and then evolving
them, maybe I think that's a promising
direction. So, that's kind of where
we're headed. And uh
yeah, so so the uh and lastly, the the
Radon transform, we're trying to
um
build a efficient implementation um and
try some things in multiple spatial
dimensions.
Um for example, variable speed uh in 2D.
So, we're trying to see if uh
all of this carries through in in two
dimensions.
Thank you. Thank you so much, Dong Seop.
Yeah, and um I'm looking forward to um
the new results in the future. I'm
uh sounds very exciting.
I I think
Sounds great.
very exciting. Uh I think uh it's time
is up. Um
it's um
Thank you. Let's thank again uh for the
today's speaker, Dong Seop. Uh thank you
so much for coming and give a wonderful
talk. And and few announcements before
we um you know adjourn.
Our next the seminar the DDPS seminar
series will be next week.
It's unusual we usually meet every two
weeks but we will have another week
another another seminar next week
due to the Thanksgiving break.
So
so please join us next week and we'll
meet again.
Until then
Bye.
Thank you Donza. Thank you.